[Music]
an evil is coming
that threatens our kingdom
our freedom
but we have a weapon
they are not prepared for
[Music]
my king the europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop until the whole of
africa is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
some things
are worth fighting for
don't know
you are called to join the king's god
no kingdom in all of
i offer you a choice
fight
or we die
you must kill your tears
[Music]
we are the homies
don't know take my power
[Music]
carol i don't know what you think you're
doing this excuse me hello
[Music]
got a dead white man in a box
not even a casket
doesn't even have a top on it
in a pine box of old wood
what do you think's gonna get in trouble
here
do me a favor try to be optimistic
you don't get here
without things starting a long time ago
[Music]
so two soldiers
and a nurse found ourselves in
amsterdam
we formed the pact and we swore to
protect each other
no matter what
we find ourselves in a situation where
we're accused of killing someone which
is not true
you and woodman fled the scene the
killer pointed at us we didn't do
anything why would you possibly think
that was us
well there's not too many people that
fit the description of a doctor looking
for his eye on the ground with his black
attorney columbia law school
love is funny we need someone to help us
to find the truth
my friend was killed
because of something monstrous that he
had seen
this is all turning out to be a lot
larger than any of us
you're gonna have to take my lead
getting out of this
i had to stab a guy i had to hit a lady
with a brick one time what
it's a long story but with you two it'll
be a cake walk
[Music]
these are dangerous times
you be careful
i'm about to do something that could
cost me my life
the cuckoo is in the nest and the
cuckoo's about to be trapped
cuckoo
[Music]
this is one of the finest innovations
from zurich it removes all pain
guys like me we have to turn the booze
the morphine and that can lead to
addiction oh that's fast
[Music]
[Music]
i know you pay
you're suffering
you've lost
yeah god protect them
[Music]
gods of the universe
i come here to raise an army
today
we'll go down in history
how exciting today we'll fight
i'm gonna kill this guy
looks probably
[Music]
[Applause]
marvel studios thor love and thunder in
theaters july 8 rated pg-13 tickets
still available
i'm sorry i think your things are in my
seat sorry
oh come on you've got to be kidding me
excuse me ma'am i need to sit somewhere
else we used to be married worst 19
years of my life we were only married
for five i'm counting the recovery
in four days time our daughter is going
to marry a guy she just met bali
millions of miles from home i just
really want to kiss you
it's like i looked up for the first time
and realized everything i ever wanted
was right in front of me
she's throwing her career away just like
her mother did so i'm the only one who
can stop her she doesn't listen in
champagne oh too please just leave the
bottle
thank you
[Applause]
i won't let her throw her life away we
need to trick her into dumping him as
much as this will paint us both we have
to call the truce to make this work good
being lockstep
did you make a pact to not murder each
other until you murder me first we are
here for you my love yes we're lost yes
promise no mean comments pretty sure you
don't win anything for eating the whole
pig no arguing
no passive aggression what about
aggressive aggression try to keep the
snoring down i have a nasal strip
it's a mystery you're still alone
mom dad this is g'day
today
you learned that to make me look bad you
don't need my help there
are you sure they're not sharks come on
don't be a chicken you might be working
with the sharks
i can't believe i got bit by a dolphin
he said pressure
[Music]
how they look disappointed
do you think we're wrong or not wrong
who are we to say that lily doesn't know
what's best for herself
[Music]
i cannot believe you what are you
talking about she found the rings where
in mom's bag
i knew it what
you clean up pretty good
there you go it's not for the faint of
heart this is not his first rodeo okay
let's go let's go can we get something a
little more age-appropriate for these
two
here we go which one there's only one i
see two
oh yeah
[Music]
oh no no dad please stop doing that
oh my god
i'm praying for an asteroid
victim's name is leo coppernick sir
seems he was killed in the costume store
[Music]
and then he was deposited here
staged so to speak
sorry
how much longer do you intend to hold it
all hostage
or is that the idea gather all the
suspects and interrogate each of us in
turn until the mysteries solve marvin
cochraners overweighted playwright
celebrated play right
oh i'm so sorry sir i can't read my own
handwriting
[Music]
there was
an incident
i'll kill you
it's as good as a confession it's not
jumpy conclusions constable
what do we have here
working late huh
he killed coppernick to hush up the
affair case close
i'm doing it again aren't you sir
jump into conclusions
you've never heard of richard
a real life detective
i understand that you came to blows
tonight in question
it was me inspector i arrest you for the
murder of leo cotton
we have a serial killer on the loose
[Music]
please stand back he keeps the key
under the map
we are no longer merely suspects
we are also
potential victims
so what did he do that made you
suspicious wasn't so much what he did it
was more the way he did it how'd he do
it sort of
suspiciously right
[Music]
oh
i blamed bad luck for everything that's
gone wrong in my life
[Music]
you sure have bad luck sam greenfield
take that universe
oh until
i found an actual lucky penny
something that could finally turn my
life around
and what did i do
i flushed it down the toilet
you flushed my panty down the toilet
you just
talked
wait i just need another penny
[Music]
who was with the obnoxiously long
password
humans cannot be here where's here
the land of luck i'll leave as soon as
you give me another lucky penny you best
start blending in hello
mighty leprechaun froy line well done
nature
this is where good luck is born
a dragon
she's the only creature that can sniff
out bad luck there's bad luck here too
good looking top bad luck on the bottom
the tiniest amount of bad luck can shut
down our entire operation
just how unlucky are you
oh no
super duper unlucky you cause a disaster
the good luck connection has been
severed
i do you and everyone else to a life of
bad luck we need to fix this
what are you doing here
good luck to us both
what about jeff
you asked i don't go down there i have
no words
[Music]
i just want to clarify some things
before we
before we get started
every woman is not built for the great
responsibility of being the first lady
pastor lee curtis childs faces
allegations of misconduct
his mega church may never be the same
lee curtis and i we're going to get to
the other side
hear that
yeah with a big old microphone come in
closer son you're going to see what all
the fuss is about
showtime what's up fresh is our turn
baby
lee curtis is a talent a star oh boy uh
we can edit around that
right this is gonna chronicle the
ultimate comeback
i'm rocky up in this fight
rocky didn't win but he did win in rocky
2.
lord baby how many times i got to tell
you get past the first movie that was
all set up
he is just so wrong
he needs someone to harness it all
god bless your heart i'm sure plenty of
the old congregation will come right on
back through good old wands of the
greater pets to us
you have a blessed one oh my goodness
and you have a blessed
i'm a sinner but i'm no criminal we need
you back in that pulpit
so you can get me back on that stage
you ain't really getting that many
babies baby shake it for
[Music]
[Applause]
all those folks out there who are gonna
see this
i want them to
know that i did what i was supposed to
do
i just don't see how that's possible
all things are possible with god that's
matthew 19 20.
so that's good you can cut
[Music]
in theaters and streaming only on
peacock september 2nd
it was always just my mom and me
to have our family that's what i really
want
no way i got a cousin that is the
whitest man i've ever seen he wants to
meet up
oliver cousin evie it sounds so jane
austen when you say it like that
you know my mom always wanted to take me
to england to learn about our family
history there's a wedding coming up
actually you should come i would love to
but come on everyone is dying to meet
you
[Music]
wow it's incredible
i believe this is one of our important
guests evie this is a close friend of
the family walter deville uh hi hi
looking forward to getting to know you
better
[Music]
what are you doing down there
miss you should return to your room
we're all so delighted that you're here
which one's the ground the groom and his
prize will make their grand entrance
tomorrow
ready
i i can't shake the feeling that
everyone is staring at me
you and walter seem to be getting off
the clothes
i'm curious though what have you told
you
about us ow
let me see
there she is where are the bride and
groom
as you all know there has been someone
missing from this table
but that once broken bond will be
renewed tonight
to even
a new bride
i want to go home but this is your home
get a prepared
help me please
yeah dear hello mr hawker here there's a
young lady who seems quite distressed
i'm so glad you've come to your senses
my love
i'm sophia
for a young man passionate about music
there's no greater place to be than
mozart's
[Music]
and what's your instrument i'm a singer
show me what you got
what what's this
there is a real magic in this walls
[Music]
what are you doing back there i have no
idea where i am
the young friends
bring back my beloved daughter you
should take a risk if you're going to
figure out what it is you're missing
i'll send you with mr mino to rescue you
so you believe me that o'clock in the
school library is a portal into mozart's
beloved masterpiece yes no
my name is honor and you're gonna say
i'm the classic overachiever i started a
school karate club and the food bank for
the economically disadvantaged while
never letting my grades suffer for me
high school is about getting out of high
school
and i'm going to the number one college
in the world honor my best and brightest
i have a connection with the admissions
people i had no idea i knew this in
ninth grade you are in my top four
choices
i'm tuning the g string wait did you say
top four
in this school of underachieving losers
there's only three people it could be
but only one is an actual threat michael
dipnicky i've got to get him to tank his
midterms what's the plan
hey michael would you be willing to
study with me yeah sure that's him sure
easy
the first wave of my campaign
throw the nerd off what's the matter we
should probably get to work because i
need a scholarship
they grow up so fast
you called him home not obsessed with
him or anything time for the evening
concert
just trying to figure him out everybody
ignores me but you don't must be so
lonely yeah you get it i do
i think
i like him
but it's just another obstacle to
overcome i'll destroy anyone who gets in
my way oh
coming to my next show i'm going to call
your mom tell her you do drugs
i just feel like you're pretending
i don't want to hurt him but i've got to
play dirty
you remember i took karate right
something's wrong nothing's wrong it's
been a four-year plan and it's coming to
a close today
here is a flyer from michelle the fire's
like a tweet that ruins the environment
i'm gonna tweak that
[Music]
[Music]
you stab me
there's someone else doing a job on this
train
it's the wolf
it was in the wedding you infiltrated in
mexico
chrome i knew i'd recognize that guy i'm
gonna go to his face get off the train
he doesn't need a reason to kill people
like you
he needs a reason not to
[Music]
we okay take your time out here i could
never stop coming for you why
[Music]
bullet train do you think there was a
little head trauma
maybe a little bit yeah exclusively in
theaters august 5th
hey happy birthday
thanks so what are you guys doing
tonight
birthday press roll scary movie marathon
same as every year
you know legend has it it's on the 16th
birthday that a witch gets her powers
another year begins a new
[Music]
manifest
[Music]
[Music]
it's the yes sisters i bet you're
looking for the stage
[Music]
always
[Music]
[Applause]
hey rick you're following what's
happening in thailand
some kids stuck in a cave
[Music]
we're on the list of rescue divers
it's just a tourist cave it looks easy
but when it's flooded it's impossible
it takes a certain kind of mindset for
the deep cave diving you have to be a
bit nuts they're very very dangerous
high water level and the law with
stability barely shoulder-wide pulling
against very strong cameras
last seen nine days ago 12 boys and
their coach are trapped in the flooded
caves
hello
hey
they're here
how many of you 13
13. they're all enough uh can we
go out now
you're talking about the hour dime
you try and dive those kids the whole
way all you've been bringing out is dead
bodies
with oxygen running low the entire
nation is anxiously waiting for what
will happen next
what are you thinking
just a crazy idea
what a skill none of the rest of us have
no
it's insane it's unethical it's illegal
man's already died
but do nothing we'll be bringing them
out there for sure
so you are expecting casualties
yes
[Music]
johnny okay yeah okay just give me a
minute
[Music]
okay
we can make it
[Music]
hey check this out
[Music]
three days of paddling three days don't
worry we'll take it easy on you
i thought i had something
that thing is stalking us
we have to help her the next island
there's reception in people okay what
about boats
we head for that island it'll come for
us again
it's not going to stop
[Music]
[Music]
somebody get over
[Music]
that's how we did it in the 90s son
i can't catch my breath man really
should i try mouth stuff what is this a
tinder date get off of me oh
mr dante i need an ambulance at the
quick stop
you saved my life man i wish i had a
life worth saving what are you talking
about sit around and watch the same
movies over and over i always thought
you could have made a cool movie you're
right i'm living on borrowed time no
more watching movies i'm gonna make a
movie
what's the movie gonna be about it's
about him working here meta everything
in the script is something either me or
someone i know said i'm not even
supposed to be here today maybe jane
style and bob could be characters hey
and silent barber like c3po and r2d2
they've been here since the first movie
which was the last time they were cool
but they've been with the franchise so
long they still give them cameos and put
them on the lunch boxes snoopy
please tell me
i believe in you
you put in that stuff you used to say
about the death star contractors
get sued by disney no way
take off your pants
uh what the hell is this i added a scene
where you get shot i'm not letting you
kill me off in the third act what if
there's a sequel a sequel what am i a
hack
i think it needs more weed
i'm gonna do an attack
i'm gonna attack a plane
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
to a terrorist attack your landing
clearance has been denied
until further notice you are not
permitted to land anywhere
you are not permitted to land anywhere
you are not permitted to land anywhere
[Music]
what is it you like to talk about
my patient
hi
i know you're nervous i just want to
have a chat
i'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me
it's smiling at me
[Music]
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
[Music]
i need to find an explanation for what
happened
it's smiling at me
smiling at me
[Music]
[Music]
i found 20 cases involving 19 victims of
the direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19.
how long between each victim's death
none of them survived longer than a week
today is my fourth day i am not gonna
keep running
i have to face it
how does it make you feel
[Music]
i'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
[Applause]
[Music]
music is a world within itself
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
hello you must be the new tenants like
to prevalently at your service i said
you've met my crocodile he's an
extraordinary talent his name is lily
of the city mom i swear to you he's not
dangerous he's a crocodile okay yes
crocodiles can fight through boning yes
they have a taste for human flesh but
he's not like that he wears a scarf
and he can sing
[Music]
are you sure this is safe who wants to
be safe we're here to live i'm living as
a dangerous person
that was awesome there is
[Music]
it's his first time in a taxi
[Music]
warning this film contains an unlikable
female protagonist viewer discretion
advised
have you ever wanted to be noticed so
badly
you didn't even care what it was for
danny sanders might actually be the
worst person we've ever covered on the
show acting like she was the victim
turned a lot of people off to her i was
just gonna bleach the front bits but i'm
really not trying to get mistaken for
danny sanders
this is so [ __ ] up isn't it kevin
white women
my name is danny sanders and on april
10th a string of terrorist attacks
struck paris i almost died
just kidding
be careful what you [ __ ] wish for
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this is the welcome to the batcave
that's the batmobile and the bad
computer who's the new kid john this is
batman's son damian
well he's obviously not invulnerable
reminds me of us when we first met i was
nicer
what are you doing here aliens are
taking over the globe
[Music]
it
is time it is time it is
time
come on farm boy we gotta go save our
dads
[Music]
all right justice dweebs let's do this
thing
[Music]
[Music]
you